well i'm not really dating right now
well that was then
and this is now it is what it is yep
khloe kardashian and tristan thompson
are officially back together after
months of dating rumors a source tells
e.t that things have been going really
well with the couple chloe is doing what
she feels is right for herself
and her daughter true i'm just super
happy and content and i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and
true okay guys we know what you're
thinking
he did kiss me my family was ruined
tristan might love me whatever that
means he has no respect for me
whatsoever
but that cheating scandal between
tristan and jordan woods is a
thing in the past it's just you know
things happen and of course i'm sorry
and apologetic as much as i can be
it's just i think a little too toxic for
me to keep reliving stuff like that the
source says that chloe is aware that the
decision will likely get
a lot of criticism from her fans and
others in her life
i think this is a part of life i'm not
saying it was unfortunate
yeah but coco is blocking out the
outside voices
and staying true to her heart all
support should be going for her and how
she feels
and that's it okay but bashing either
side is just not cool for me
it's not necessary anybody i don't think
there needs to be negativity on anywhere
i think it's just a story that's being
told but anybody picking a side or
you know condemning any human as for
tristan he's been
totally there for chloe since the
coronavirus pandemic the couple have
been quarantined together to
really connect and enjoy one another
honestly and truthfully i just want us
to have
a peaceful friendship and
distance yeah tristan's been really
consistent
and present and that's great what's also
great
co-parenting their two-year-old daughter
true in april it was
a party of three for their baby girl's
second birthday
good job did you make a wish
in july a source told et that at the end
of the day chloe wants her daughter true
to have both her parents around as much
as possible
and if they can make it work she wants
to try chloe has gone through a lot and
has reiterated that to tristan who
insists he has changed i always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
[Music]
people